BARTON 86. WHAT ARE THE ODDS
THAT MATTHEW STAFFORD
ACTUALLY ENDS UP IN
INDIANAPOLIS EVERYTHING I
HEAR. OH FANS WITH SOURCES
SAYS THAT BALLARD WANTS HIM.
AND THAT STAFFORD WANTS TO
COME TO ND I HAVE YET TO HEAR
THAT BUT HEY, THE COLTS NEED
A QUARTERBACK STAFFORDS
AVAILABLE. THE QUESTION IS
WHAT DID LINES WANT FOR HIM?
AND I THINK IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE. THEY WONT BE
COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER
WITH STAFFORD INSTEAD OF
PHILIP RIVERS SHIREEN.
I CERTAINLY THINK HE FITS
THEIR MY KEY FITS WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO IF ITS FRANK
REICH SAW FENCE AND HE COULD
BE THERE FOR MORE THAN ONE
YEAR AS A BRIDGE QUARTERBACK.
SO A LOT DEPENDS LIKE YOU
SAID ON WHAT THE LIONS WANT
WILLING TO GIVE UP FOR HIM?
THEY DIDNT HAVE TO GIVE UP
ANYTHING TO GET PHILIP RIVERS.
THEY JUST HAD TO SIGN HIM TO
A CONTRACT AND FRANKLY. IT
WAS A TEAM FRIENDLY DEAL THAT
THEY GOT WITH PHILIP RIVERS
LAST YEAR. SO HERE THEY ARE
LOOKING FOR QUARTERBACK JIM,
BUT I THINK IT MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE.
I DONT KNOW THAT ID SAY 25
MILLION DOLLARS FOR PHILIP
RIVERS AT THAT POINT IN HIS
CAREER IS TEAM FRIENDLY,
ESPECIALLY WHEN BRADY GOT 25
MILLION AS WELL. I THOUGHT IT
WAS MORE SKI MASK CONTRACT
FOR PHILIP RIVERS, BUT HEY,
YOU KNOW REASONABLE MINDS CAN
DIFFER. HERES ANOTHER ONE
JUMANJI AVIAN AS COULD. DO
YOU THINK MATTHEW STAFFORD
DOME STADIUM BECAUSE HES E
BEEN PLAYING IN ONE OR WOULD
IT BE NO PROBLEM IF HE GOES
TO DENVER NOW, LOOK ID HAVE
TO DO A FULL ANALYSIS ON HIS
STATISTICS PLAYING OUTSIDE
VERSUS INSIDE, BUT EVERY
QUARTERBACK WANTS TO PLAY IN
SIT ATTRACTIVE ITS JUST ONE
OF THE WHEN YOU LIST THE PROS
AND CONS ONE OF THE PROS THAT
YOU CHECK IS DOME STADIUM,
RIGHT?
YEAH, AND YOU TALK ABOUT
LAMAR JACKSON. I REMEMBER WE
WERE WRITING THOSE STORIES.
HES NEVER PLAYED IN A SNOW
GAME IN HIS LIFE. HE HADNT
EVEN SEEN SNOW UNTIL HE GOT
TO LOUISVILLE AND THEY HAD A
SNOWBALL FIGHT, BUT HE NEVER
PLAYED IN IT THERE. AND SO A
LOT OF THESE QUARTERBACKS HAD
NEVER PLAYED IN STOWE. I
DONT KNOW HOW MANY SNOW
GAMES MATTHEW STAFFORD HIS
PLATE AND HE GREW UP HERE IN
DALLAS. HE DIDNT PLAY IN
MANY IT FIT ANY SNOW GAMES IN
HIGH SCHOOL. HE WENT TO
GEORGIA AND YOU CAN PLAY IN
MANY IF ANY SNOW GAMES COLE
GAMES AND GEORGIE
EITHER SO HE
BUT I DONT KNOW THINK SE MIKE,
QUARTERBACKS CAN ADJUST AND
THEN GO WHERE THEY WHERE THEY
RATHER PLAY IN A DOME. IM
SURE HE WOULD RATHER PLAY IN
INDIANAPOLIS THAN SOMEWHERE
THAN DENVER MAYBE AS FAR AS
WANT TO GO AND HAVE A CHANCE
TO WIN WHEREVER THAT IS. BEST
PLACE FOR HIM. I THINK IS A
SPOT THAT HAS STRONG VETERAN
LEADERSHIP NOT RELYING UPON
THE QUARTERBACK TO PROVIDE
ITS STRONG COACHING NOT
RELYING UPON THE QUARTERBACK
TO PROVIDE IT AND COACHING
THAT IS STRONG ENOUGH TO
ELEVATE THE QUARTERBACK
BECAUSE
IVE NEVER GOTTEN THE
IMPRESSION. HE CRAVES THE
MANTLE OF BEING A LEADER
THATS BEEN THE ONE FLAW IN
HIS GAME AND YOU REALLY HAVE
TO BE PICKY TO FIND THAT BUT
HES A GREAT PASTOR GREAT
QUARTERBACK AND COULD MAKE A
TEAM GREAT NEXT YEAR. VENNETT,
TEXANS AND THE PACKERS THE
SWAPPING QUARTERBACKS AARON
RODGERS FOR DESHAUN WATSON
SHEREE, WHAT WOULD YOU THINK
OF THAT?
OH, THAT WOULD BE SO AWESOME
TO ME, BUT I COULDNT SEE WHY
AARON RODGERS WOULD POSSIBLY
WANT TO GO TO THE TEXANS. I
MEAN YOU LOOK AT WHAT DESHAUN
WATSON DID WITH THE TEXAS
THIS YEAR. HE LED THE LEAGUE
IN PASSING YARDS AND LOOK
WHAT IT GOT HIM FOUR WINS.
THEY ARE NOT CLOSE TO BEING A
SUPER BOWL CHAMPION, BUT I
THINK THAT WOULD BE EXCITING
TO WATCH I THINK TESHON WATTS
WOULD BE TERRIFIC IN GREEN
AARON RODGERS SAYING TO
JACKIES TO BE GET THE
EXPLETIVE DELETED OUT OF MY
FACE WOULD BE THREE AND A
HALF SECONDS.
SO FOR THAT REASON ALONE, I
WANT THE TRADE TO HAPPEN PFT
P.M. POLICY WHAT WAS WRONG
WITH OUR BOY BLUE DURING
YESTERDAYS GAME? THATS A
REFERENCE OBVIOUSLY TO BILLS
QUARTERBACK JOSH ALLEN OR
WHAT DID THE CHIEFS DEFENSE
DO THAT HAD HIM SO RATTLED
AND OUT OF SYNC. I LOOK I
THINK IT WAS A COMBINATION OF
THE MOMENT PLUS THE CHIEFS
DEFENSE IS PRETTY GOOD. CHRIS
JONES SEEM TO BE EVERYWHERE
THAT I SAW JOSH ALAN
YESTERDAY, AND HE JUST HE
JUST WAS OFF AND THEYVE GOT
A GREAT SECONDARY. VERY
GREAT PASS RUSH. VERY
WE TALKED ABOUT
ABOUT MY HOMES AND TYRIQ AND
OFFENSE OFFENSE. THE CHIEFS
AND THE BILLS WALKED RIGHT
YEAH, AND YOU LOOK AT JOSH
ALLENS ELEVATION MIKE. HE
WENT FROM GETTING THE BILLS
TO THE SUIT TO THE PLAYOFFS
LAST YEAR AND THEY LOST
HOUSTON. THEY SHOULDNT HAVE
THIS YEAR. HE GET SOME WINS.
HE GETS HIM TO THE
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME. THEYVE
TAKEN ANOTHER STEP. I THINK
NEXT YEAR. THEYLL BE
EXPECTING TO TAKE THAT NEXT
STEP WHICH IS GET TO THE
SUPER BOWL AND HES TAKEN ALL
THOSE STEPS MAHOMES LOST HIS
FIRST TIME IN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME TO NOW THEY
SHOULD HAVE WON THE GAME AS
WE SAID EARLIER, BUT HE DID
LOSE HIS FIRST ONE. I THINK
ITS ALL ABOUT TAKING THOSE
STEPS.
I THINK HE DID THAT THIS YEAR,
BUT HE DIDNT LOOK GOOD IN
THAT GAME FOR SURE. THERE HAS
BEEN A REAL BUZZ IN LEAGUE
CIRCLES PEOPLE WHO STUDY THE
GAME PEOPLE WHO ARE AT THE
ALAN PLAY WERE QUESTIONING
WHETHER OR NOT ALLEN HAS
CAUGHT PATRICK MAHOMES NOW,
THATS REGULAR SEASON MAHOMES
AND REGULAR SEASON ALLEN
THERE IS SOMETHING ABOUT
PLAYOFF MAHOMES THAT RISES TO
ANOTHER LEVEL AND YOU KNOW,
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS EVERY
WEEK OF THE REGULAR SEASON.
THE CHIEFS ARE
TAKING THE ABSOLUTE BEST
PUNCH THAT THE OPPONENT HAS
THEY ARE THE MEASURING STICK.
THE CHIEFS ARE WEEK IN AND
WEEK OUT IT BECOMES
EXHAUSTING AND THEN YOU GET
TO THE PLAYOFFS. ITS FULL
FOCUS ITS NEXT LEVEL AND
THATS WHAT WE SAW FROM A
SIMPLY WASNT ABLE TO MEET AN
THAT LEVEL OF PERFORMANCE,
YEAH, AND I SAW TONY DUNGY
TWEET THIS OUT MAHOMES.
THEYRE AVERAGING 36 POINT
ONES. YALL POINTS IN THE
POSTSEASON GAMES. HE STARTED
AND FINISHED IT. THEYVE HAD
HES HAD 15 DRIVES IN THE
POSTSEASON THIS YEAR SEVEN
MISSED FIELD GOAL ONE PUNT A
AND TO KNEEL DOWNS THIS
OFFENSE ROLES WHEN THEY GET
TO THE POSTSEASON AND THEYRE
DOING IT AGAIN MIKE LAST ONE
REAL QUICKLY FROM NELLIE WITH
WHY SHOULD THE NFL HAVE
SUPER BOWL THIS YEAR A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE BUZZING ABOUT THAT
WHY TAKE TWO WEEKS TO LET ONE
OF THESE TEAMS DEVELOP A
AN ISSUE, LETS KEEP THIS
THING ROLLING IN MY GUESS IS
THERE ARE PLENTY OF PEOPLE TO
LEAD OFFICER FOR THINKING MAN.
IF THERE WAS ONLY A WAY WE
COULD JUST PLAY THIS DAMN
GAME SUNDAY AND BE DONE WITH
BECAUSE WHO KNOWS WHATS
GOING TO HAPPEN OVER THE NEXT
YEAH, AND WE GOT NO PRO BOWL.
THEY DONT NEED THAT ANYWAY,
BUT WE DONT HAVE IT THIS
WEEKEND. THEY COULD HAVE
PLAYED IT THIS WEEKEND. BUT
OBVIOUSLY THE SCHEDULE IS
PREDETERMINED. THE SUPER BOWL
IS PRESET. NO WAY REALLY TO
MOVE THIS THING. LIKE THEY
PROBABLY WANT TO BUTT IN BEST
LAID PLANS. ABSOLUTELY.
THEYD WANT TO PLAY THE GAME
THIS SUNDAY RATHER THAN WAIT
ANOTHER WEEK AND THE THREAT
OF AN OUTBREAK REAL QUICKLY
JBOSS IS JOSH MCDANIELS EVER
GOING TO BE A HEAD COACH
NO.
TO BE A NEW ENGLAND THOUGH. I
DONT KNOW. WHY WOULD HE IF
HES HOT BELCHECK BOYS TO
THE EAGLES ABOUT WHAT WAS ONE
OF THE LEAST DESIRABLE JOBS
THIS CYCLE IF HE THOUGHT
HE WAS GOING TO GET THE
B
AT SOME POINT. UNLESS BILL
BELICHICK REALLY IS GOING TO
GO WARREN BUFFETT RUPERT
MURDOCH COACH INTO HIS
EIGHTIES, BUT FOLKS LOOK WE
THIS AND AND THEN GEORGE
HALAS RETIRED FROM COACHING
WHEN HE DID FOR ONE VERY
SIMPLE REASON. HE COULDNT
STAND FOR THREE HOURS ANYMORE.
THERE WILL BE A POINT WHERE
PHYSICALLY ACCOMPLISH THE TO
DEMANDS OF THE JOB. SO WHAT
DO YOU DO? YOURE GOING TO
WOULD IT WOULD YOU GOING TO
DO AT THAT POINT SO I DONT
THINK BAIL CHECKS GOING TO BE
THERE ANOTHER 10 YEARS, BUT
YOU KNOW FROM A DANIEL
STANDPOINT THAT THE SUN HAS
SET ON ON HIS A-LIST STATUS
AS EVIDENCE BY THE FACT THAT
HE INTERVIEWED WITH THE
EAGLES THEY SEEM TO BE
YEAH, AND IF MIKE IF HE EVER
GETS AN OPPORTUNITY, HE
BETTER TAKE THAT JOB BECAUSE
I THINK IT WILL BE HIS LAST
OPPORTUNITY, BUT I DONT
THINK HE EVER GETS ANOTHER
CHANCE. HE TURNED DOWN THE
COLTS AND THAT WAS HIS BEST
OPPORTUNITY TO GO BE A HEAD
COACH SOMEWHERE ELSE AND IM
WITH YOU. IM NOT SURE HE
GETS THE NEW ENGLAND JOB. I
THINK BELICHICK IS SETTING UP
ONE OF HIS SONS TO TAKE OVER
THAT JOB WHEN HES DONE. NOW
WHAT ROBERT KRAFT WANTS TO DO
IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
THING, BUT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE WHAT BILL BELICHICK WOULD
WANT IS ONE OF HIS SONS TO
GET THAT JOB. YEAH, ROBERT.
SETTING UP ONE OF HIS SONS TO
RUN THE TEAM AND THAT SONS
GOT TO BE ON BOARD WITH A SON
OF BELICHICK TAKEN OVER THE
PATRIOTS. SO, LETS SEE HOW
THAT ALL PLAYS OUT. BUT ONE
OF THOSE ARE BOTH OF THOSE
KIDS GOING TO END UP BEING A
HEAD COACH SOMEWHERE BECAUSE
BELICHICK AND YOURE JUST
GOING TO ASSUME THEY KNOW
WHAT THEYRE DOING AND ALSO
THEY HAVE SOMEBODY I CAN CALL
ON THE PHONE FOR ADVICE
ANYTIME THEY WANT.